el suministro de aviones de casa a
Ucrania por parte de la Unión Europea
siguen entredicho No hay forma de que
los aviones de combate puedan ser
entregados en las próximas semanas
porque hay retrasos en la formación en
el envío no se puede acortar la
formación para aviones que no conocen
los pilotos ucranianos Así que no lo
excluyen lo absoluto pero no se
corresponde con la demanda actual
[Aplausos]
el presidente
de su gira por Europa pide que le envíen
aeronaves para contrarrestar la ofensiva
rusa por su parte Polonia deja la
decisión en manos de la organización del
tratado Atlántico Norte
[Aplausos]
el debate sobre los aviones de combate
tendría que ser una decisión por parte
de la otan y Polonia decidirá por
nuestra parte Qué hacer si hay tal
decisión unánime por parte de la otan de
que los aviones de combate pueden ser
transferidos a Ucrania
y las sanciones nuevamente en escena la
presidenta de la comisión europea dio
detalles sobre un nuevo paquete en
discusión que se centraría en dejar a
Moscú si los bienes militares que
necesita
sobre el valor de 10 mil millones de
euros más o menos del paquete de
sanciones contra Rusia Esto está
dirigido a bienes que son casi
irremplazables de otro lugar
y miramos profundamente en la maquinaria
de guerra de Rusia donde podemos definir
tecnologías o piezas de repuesto que
están siendo utilizadas por el complejo
militar pero en las que podemos porque
somos el único proveedor prohibir la
exportación de eso
continúa sus visitas a los aliados
europeos mientras el kremlin advierte
que el envío de nuevo armamento a que
Escala aún más las pensiones